ridiculous liberal bail reform policy is
now at the center of the horrific
christmas parade attack that killed five
people and injured 48 others we're now
learning the suspect career criminal
darryl brooks was out on a thousand
dollar bond and set free just days
before this terrible tragedy brooks was
charged with punching his girlfriend and
then trying to intentionally run her
over with his car
and police saying he was fleeing another
domestic violence incident before
driving into the parade
we have information that the suspect
prior to incident was involved in a
domestic disturbance
which was just minutes prior
and the suspect left that scene just
prior to our arrival
to the domestic disturbance we actually
had a squad and barricades up
and he drove right through
the milwaukee county district attorney
is now launching an internal review into
what he's calling an inappropriately low
bail amount
yeah judge this d.a is the guy that
likes low bail he like ran on that yeah
he did run on it so you know i like what
he's doing what he's doing here is he's
saying i'm going to take care of this
everybody no problem i don't know who
the lowest person on the totem pole is
who went to court on this case but that
person is in big trouble no it's you the
d.a who's big trouble and i'll tell you
why this is a rap sheet okay it's got i
hear i say i understand to have 50 pages
what you don't know in addition to
what we know from the news and that is
that he had a felony charged against him
in july of 2020 he was already out on
bail had another felony charged against
him on november 2nd
and uh he has been violated for bail and
then he goes to court on november 5th
and they give him bail at a thousand
dollars but that's not the least of it
this guy in all of these charges he's a
batterer he's a drug addict he's been
carrying a gun since he was 18 years old
and he got all the benefits of the
criminal justice system but where he's
caused strangulation against one woman
then he causes strangulation against
another woman or the same woman this
time it has to be a felony and they
force the prosecutor to file a felony
but you go through this and through all
the police arrests there's no
prosecution
so this guy has used the system the d.a
is the person who's at fault here not
the bail law that you would allow a guy
who just jumped bail to give him a
thousand dollars bail is ridiculous and
greg if you watch cnn it is a red suv
that's responsible for this carnage it's
not his fault he was fleeing a knife
fight all right so the root cause the
root cause here is knife violence and he
was just a victim of systemic knife
violence also i mean an suv think of the
carbon footprint you know whoever
thought that putting violent criminals
back on the streets was a wise decision
i think under the rubric of reform we
let our brains spill out of our skulls
it's like we are releasing piranhas into
an aquarium of goldfish and it's not
just with bail for reform it's this
stuff like this it's also interesting
how the stories depending on what
narrative they sell uh are turned off or
turned on uh i could do the story like
what if this guy was white because they
were doing the thing with rittenhouse
what if this guy was black but it's
obvious that this story fulfills the
wrong narrative so it's
it's not going to be wall-to-wall
coverage they're going to say the same
people that said rittenhouse
intentionally went to kenosha to
murder these guys uh will say that this
career criminal unintentionally killed
people and how soon before they they
label him you know a victim
and then and the police chief said today
he's charging him with five counts of
intentional homicide and we've been
investigating a social media footprint
harold mann i can't confirm it yet but
this guy is
bad news
bad news from his social
i'm talking about motivation right i'm
talking about motivation
look there's not much to add to this
this guy i judge i think i love the way
you i should say i appreciate the way
you analyze this is the bell reform we
should have bail reform but this issue
here was this prosecutor here not doing
his or her job but we need more
resources to ensure that no you don't
need resources
who knows what he's got to do the city
can't you sorry
i'm only saying if we need if there is a
need for more staffing around for this
whatever that is i don't know what this
was it pure incompetence i agree with
you i'm only saying 50 pages how long
does it take for you to catch
incompetence yeah i mean my
seven-year-old probably could have
figured this out without a law degree uh
so the guy i agree i don't i don't know
what more to add other than we as a
nation i'm excited to see and encourage
to see the police chief i don't know if
he's a democrat or republican he
appeared to be african-american that
he's you said five intentional acts he's
being charged he's charging a person
with we need law enforcement and we need
district attorneys and prosecutorial
teams that are going to enforce the law
and most important the reason you
enforce the law is to protect the public
and serve the public and hopefully get
more people wanting to do that can't
people sue the city if they're not if
they're not enforcing the law i mean
this has got to be this is clear
misconduct on behalf of the city yeah
and there was no police pursuit
absolutely no so he's not purposely
plowing his car
whether it's foreseeable if something is
foreseeable then or
okay
but that i do think that
either they have to be sued or something
has to happen because here's the thing
um
this guy
has ruined the lives of so many people
right before christmas they'll never get
over it
and the only justice might be that this
uh process and of having very left-wing
progressive district attorneys
prosecutors that are not prosecuting
crimes that there it only takes one case
to become a rallying cry i think this
one should be it if we're going to have
to have a conversation about gun laws
every time there's a shooting
then it stands to reason that we should
have a conversation about
prosecutorial misconduct which i think
this is of the highest order but it's
happening not just in kenosha it's
happening in cities all across america
we've been talking about it and i think
that um starting next year in those
elections and the ones that are coming
is already happening in seattle they
don't want to defund the police all
across the board this case should be the
rallying cry to end it i have to say one
more thing the judge is also at fault
the judge knew what the record was of
this offender he had just run over the
mother of his child with his car and he
lets him out when he had already jumped
bail he lets him out on bail i mean this
is total stupidity or not caring about
the rule of law period sorry and our
hearts go out to the families of
waukesha
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else